- All right, I think
What in the hell are
you doing, Chumlee?
Building something
for your son.
Hey, there he is.
What's this?
Check it out, the
"USS Chum," that
submarine you always wanted.
Um.
That is a dumbest
looking submarine
I've ever seen in my life.
You ordered yourself
food, and have no money.
Well, I thought I
had my wallet here.
But I left my
wallet in my house.
I thought it was in my car.
Anyways, can I borrow 20 bucks?
Hold on.
I got the pizza
on the way already.
Here, sign that.
What is that?
It's promissory note, proof
that you borrowed $20 from me.
You will get this note
back when you pay me back.
Now, sign that.
So whoever holds that note,
I have to pay 20 bucks to?
It's the way
promissory notes work.
Do you understand?
You get this back
when you pay me back.
Where's the promissory
note I had you sign?
You owe me 20
bucks now because I
bear the promissory note.
Why are you in my seat?
FRANKENSTEIN: [inaudible].
RICK: Is that thing merchandise?
Every time someone
says anything
to him for the past hour, he
just pulls the cord on that.
RICK: Go put it away.
FRANKENSTEIN: You re so cute.
I'm green with envy.
Chumlee, go in the back.
I have a bone record.
CHUMLEE: What is a bone record?
It's an X-ray.
It's like an X-ray record that
they use for like band music
back in the day.
RICK: You know, it's definitely
an X-ray of something,
it looks like.
CHUMLEE: Looks like boobs.
CUSTOMER: It's not boobs.
Maybe I'm just seeing things.
RICK: Chum, what are you doing?
Working.
You're making
a paper airplane.
That's not working.
I'm at work.
I'm getting paid to be here.
It doesn't fit.
Actually, it fits
you pretty good
and hides the fact
that you're bald.
You're making a board game now?
Yeah, it's called Chum Life.
There's nothing on it, Chum.
I was hoping you guys would
kind of help me, you know,
fill the squares out and get the
idea of the game a little bit.
What about takes boss's truck
to get lunch and wrecks it.
I've got some
rare whistles here.
RICK: OK.
[blows whistles]
Sounds like a train.
RICK: I hear it, Chum.
That's definitely
a train whistle.
I actually went out and bought
a new pair of shoes last night.
So I'm going to write those off.
RICK: How are you going
to write off shoes?
I have to wear
them to work, duh.
RICK: There's Chum.
This is what you looks
like in night vision.
This is what I look
like at night, too.
[laughs]
I just spent a lot of
money on two $500 bills.
That's dumb they're
only worth $1,000.
RICK: [sighs] Do you know
about the Battle of the Bulge?
I think it was like
December 16, 1944.
And I know it was
like a pretty big
battle on the Western Front.
Um, yeah.
Every once in a while
you shock me, Chum.
I'm the luckiest
person in the world.
Why are you so lucky?
Obviously he's lucky.
10 years, he's still here.
CHUMLEE: Pretty
awesome, isn't it, Rick?
Yeah.